all right joe talk to us about roku
we're gonna we're gonna do let joe do a
victory lap right now
this is this is uh this is me offering
him an olive branch joe's gonna do his
victory lap on roku we're gonna start
with
uh what was the thesis for roku
when you first decided to take the
plunge
when did you first decide to take the
plunge as well it was like shortly after
the ipo 2017-2018 oh you're
you're a post-ipo guy okay yeah i didn't
have the opportunity to get we need to
change those laws
all right so what happened with roku no
so roku the main story is
a lot of people don't know this but roku
was actually founded within netflix so
netflix was originally going to go out
and create a hardware service
uh they iterated on it for a couple
years and then eventually they said hey
we want to be agnostic to hardware and
we're just going to kind of
spin it out and divest it so roku was
born in 2007
they they worked at it for 10 or so
years and then they went public in 2017
2017-2018 and my main thought process
behind it was actually pretty simple it
was just that um
you know it's it's more of a plan on
cord cutting right so the idea that
cable was going to continue to decline
in the united states
uh and abroad and more people were going
to search for uh streaming content and
not only streaming content but roku was
very clear from the beginning that they
wanted
they were more focused on free and
ad-supported content because they
believed that people's entertainment
budgets were going to shrink as more of
these services
uh as 2017 all these companies were
going out and making these premium
services that were 10 15 20
a month so they said hey look we're
gonna keep ours free and we're gonna
make most of our money on advertising
so the way they do it is they sell uh
they sell a couple hardware products now
they have the streaming stick that is
very similar to uh
amazon's fire stick and they have uh
like an actual
like uh you know hard unit like a block
but most of their units the stat that
really surprised me and i've told you
guys about this in the past was
when i looked at it first uh i saw that
i think it was nearly one-third of all
television sold within the us and i
think canada also
included a roku already built into the
tv so you go to walmart wherever you go
best buy
you buy a tv one out of every three sold
there already included roku installed on
the unit so
the chances were and a lot of those tvs
were the cheaper ones right so
if you look at the chart we have on the
screen now that's really helped roku
from a market share standpoint they own
about 50
of the streaming devices worldwide and
the craziest part about this chart is
that number is even higher if you just
look within us and canada they're only
in about 20 countries so far
and they're really just starting to span
expand internationally so they have a
massive market share especially uh kind
of here domestically in the united
states
and that was really because they went
and they said hey look we're not just
gonna produce the device the hardware
we're gonna go and we're actually gonna
get installed in every single tv that
you guys go and purchase
all right i have questions let's hear it
who are the competitors to roku
uh is it like an amazon fire stick yeah
it's all the ones on those charts amazon
fire stick apple so they're about two
times bigger uh than amazon they're much
bigger maybe six or seven times
uh bigger than apple tv uh but it's yeah
it's all those streaming platforms but
the
the unique thing is it's really just a
marketplace right so they offer you the
ability to go on you can watch your
uh you can watch your hbo you can watch
your hulu you can watch all those kind
of different streaming platforms
within their unit and then they just
charge they charge an advertising fee
uh they make money on ads and then they
make money uh for
kind of referral fees so anytime you
sign up for hulu through the
roku device they get a kickback okay
this chart right here
shows that smart tvs which was part of
your thesis saw 200
growth uh from q3 2019 to q3 2020. now
i'm assuming that a lot of that has to
do with pandemic so
let's let's handicap it it doubled right
uh is the thought process that if smart
tvs
continue to gain adoption then roku
continues to do well
or do they have other ways of uh
like getting more customers right now
they reported
55.1 million active customers and 17
billion streaming hours which is nuts
yeah so i think a lot of it
is uh just the continued adoption of
streaming services right and platforms
so if you look at
um i don't have them handy but everyone
knows cord cutting is is accelerating to
some degree here
in the united states uh it's been a
trend for a while but over the course of
the pandemic it's actually accelerated
so uh you know people are unsubscribing
from their cable packages every single
day roku is gaining market share in that
area so this chart shows it perfectly
traditional tv is down about 20
year-over-year in q2
roku was up 19 and the average streaming
platform was down two percent
so roku is expanding aggressively
internationally
average tv streaming platform what yeah
i i i'm looking at the chart
john do you see why i'm saying do you
see the asterisk
according to nielsen for persons two
years of age or older in the united
states how they measure statistics
that's how media companies measure two
years old whatever it's equal for
everyone
just as many babies are watching
traditional tv no but that's how you
guess crazy that's how you get a whole
picture of the entire demographic so a
lot of these companies they'll break it
down by
two plus 15 to 18 years old you can
break down by whatever
age age and gender demographics you want
um how you know so much about this i
used to work for one of those companies
but but the general idea right it's just
like it didn't really take that much
uh you know the conviction was high
because i thought that
i i like most people back then in 2017
2018 realized cord cutting was going to
become a thing right and it was going to
continue to be get more aggressive more
people were going to do it
more streaming services were going to
come out of it and roku more than anyone
had the opportunity to own most that
market share which they've executed on
and that's why the stock has gone up so
high
so they're growing quarters up 50 60 a
quarter year over year
that's gonna slow down over time as uh
those comps become
harder but they own fifty percent of the
market right now and that was really
because they had the ability to put all
of these units within the television so
literally if you want any tv
it's one third of all tvs but any tv
essentially under like 200
has a roku in it in the united states
all right so when we look at the numbers
28 year-over-year growth for active
accounts now 55 million
19 year-over-year growth for streaming
hours which is measured in the billions
and then the average revenue per user is
up 46 percent that's your overview
that's my favorite stat on this year
yeah they make what i didn't see it but
it's like 30 something dollars right 36
36 yes the platform revenue is
up 117 year over year
the gross profit is up 149
year over year but
the revenue estimate was 645 million
they missed they came in at 613 million
but the earnings per share estimate was
13 cents and they came in at 52 cents
yes so that happened that's the thing
though like these comps are going to get
too hard to
to it's that the stock was valued when
it's like 500 something bless you
excuse me eventually uh these these
estimates become too difficult to hit
right you're still having
30 50 60 growth in most categories uh
but when you start to look at it from
the standpoint of hey we need to do this
every quarter year over year
it becomes challenging when you're not
growing as aggressively uh domestically
so now they're searching in
international markets and stuff
but when you own 50 of the market and
you're able to charge uh
you know you're able to make 30 per
revenue off of each customer
it's obviously impressive and as this
market continues to grow from an
absolute basis as more people continue
to cord cut
then we'll see their their revenue and
kind of their user base grow over time
i'd love to see their uh
cost of customer acquisition as well i
feel like that's super low for them
yeah i mean well when you think about it
being already installed in the tvs that
lowers it
so can i uh uh bring up one one uh
negative data point is that all right
double zero no not devil's advocate
well let's be clear your boy's out the
stock
your boys
do we have the stock price let me see
let's see let's pull up the stock price
because i want to be clear that joe this
was a very good investment
joe was correct he didn't say that again
no
all clever very good very winners what
did what was it
uh uh this is what i call next yeah this
is what i call the 10x dance
wait what what is the 10x ants
but were you only up 10x yeah oh
bitcoin did this no no no what was that
what was the percentage yeah i was
yeah a thousand percent 1000 okay all
right give or take good job
nice nice clap it up for jail that's
what i'm talking about zach
[Applause]
very good very good now why did the
stock fall they
are actually down a billion streaming
hours from q1 to q2
in 2021 and people are saying that oh
everyone was locked in their house last
you know q2q3 and now that they're
coming out they're not watching as much
television with roku is that something a
concern
now that you are uh a minuscule roku
investor rather than a big roku investor
you can we go to the five-year chart uh
right there so joe if you go all the way
to the left of the chart
let's go there post-ip no farther
farther farther farther jump
somewhere in this area you know do you
know what you're when you first bought
it do you remember what the price was
yeah it was like 30 something but the
cost base is probably oh 30 oh
it wasn't it was like it was yeah it was
like yeah it was like in that
like that kind of like little area so i
had to wait
around 2018 but 30s 40s yeah right in
there
hey i was dollar cost averaging multiple
times killed
all right sales good strategy all right
and then where were you selling yeah i
was uh you see that really high peak
i was right on the back side of that i
was right on the back side of that right
over there somewhere like in the 390s
350 yeah yeah yeah yeah like i think i
was probably uh right around where we
are now to be honest
like 350 okay 400. so so why did you
sell
uh for those same reasons why the it's
it was valued really super at a super
high multiple because it's a growth
company
and as uh they reach their kind of
potential within the us it's gonna be
difficult to match those comps so like
they're up 50 60 the other day and the
stock fell because they didn't meet
estimates
right so it's challenging and then yeah
it's you're playing uh back into the
pandemic right so same reason peloton
stock declined
uh when when the vaccine rolled out and
all these other things because people
are returning they're not gonna watch it
watch as much tv at home and what other
stocks do you own
let's just get that out on the table not
many now not many now i only i only mess
around with a couple things you know you
gotta have
i was very convinced on roku i told
y'all y'all say he didn't
i told every single no you didn't tell
me you told them i told you didn't i
i said buy roku you didn't say buy
regular you would have had a 10 bagger
johnny
[Laughter]
wait john what did he say he didn't say
to buy roku he came in one day and he
was like hey like i bought some roku
today and then came in like a month
later i was like hey i bought some more
roku today yeah every time like more
more more and then did you tell anyone
when you sold it did you call it no one
bought it so i didn't have to tell
anyone i'm not gonna call up strangers
all right so well i'm out so don't take
this as financial advice i don't know if
you'll make money i have no idea
i'm out do you like roku yeah i mean are
you a user
uh not anymore wow wow you sold the
stock and you dumped the service
wow well hey that's fair hey if you're
not wow i didn't like the stock anymore
unsubscribed no but
it was like it was built into an old you
know what people say right like if you
buy
built into an old television buy like
nike shoes you should buy one share a
nike stock like you know invest in the
products you use
so what you did was the opposite you
said i'm dumping the stock i'm dumping
the services
y'all made me my money so what what do
you use for tv now maybe i should go run
over there
no it was built the real reason why i
used it was and i didn't actually think
roku was
the best player in the space uh from
like a kind of platform standpoint i
think there's better ones like better
functionality
but roku was installed on the tv i had
no choice like
otherwise i would go out and buy an
apple tv or whatever so it was already
installed that's why i used it and
that's why i thought a lot of other
people were going to use it and to be
clear you've sold
most of your position but you still have
five percent left someone said i'm bag
holding yeah
i got the stocks back up 400. i'm
keeping a little exposure
why because i'm gonna be rich off it now
i i i left a little bit i left a little
bit it's got like a
nice spot in your heart your first time
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's got a little
upside down
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com
so that you can get an account we can
get after it